I'm going to talk about a new algorithm
for data fitting today and this is going
to be joined talk I'm a mathematician
and Mustafa to see is a computer
scientist we worked it to other people
on this project one medical doctor dr.
Dana Marshall from Meharry Medical
College in nashville tennessee and we
also work with one high school student
who was a student in academy and taking
all the university level courses instead
of high school level courses so i looked
at the math part of the project and
mustapha looked at the computer part of
it which is about using and writing
programming in Mathematica student
helped us for with the running of the
codes because we have large data not as
large as you think we have a board with
a mouse data and we also collaborated
with medical doctor and we asked her
what are you doing how our work will
help you in your research as well as in
your area dealing with you know people
so first I like to start with some
introduction to mathematics part of the
problem so this is about discrete
fractional calculus it is a new area in
mathematics the first paper published in
1970s then there was a get after than in
2006 we published a paper so between
1972 2006 Star Wars not much papers
published about discrete fractional
calculus and discrete frictional
modeling so i will talk about three
Nerys of discrete fractional calculus
first and I'm I'm gonna introduce you
fractional exponential functions you
probably heard about me talk left our
function and behave a discrete version
of mr. gresner function in discrete
fractional calculus I am going to focus
on combat curves Palmer's curve fits
very well with cancel cancer or tomorrow
growth models so we are going to use
combats curves for data fitting I'm
going to introduce you discrete
fractional combats equation again a
first time because the theory is Nev
discrete version is new so Mathematica
doesn't know how to solve it so we need
something else a new method for
parameter estimation for data fitting
and then I'm going to discuss how good
the feet we are doing in our short okay
let's start with just three basic things
about the fractional calculus I'm not
sure how many of us are mathematicians
but most of us probably using
mathematics derivatives and integrals we
use integer orders like we are talking
about first order derivative second
order derivative and anta Claus just
single integral double integrals but the
order is one for fractional calculus we
are talking about half order derivative
pie order derivative ye order integra so
this is what a fractional calculus about
and they done there is a discrete
version of it for discrete calculus we
have some operators and we have a
difference operators so we have a you
know so far we talked about first order
difference equations second order
differences
but after discrete fractional calculus
now we have half order difference
equations eat ordered order difference
equations so we are frictional izing the
order of equations the there is a little
history we believe in mathematicians
believe that frictional calculus was
born in 916 and 95 ran lightness and
local were exchanging ideas about the
notation for and derivative and look to
ask lightness what if n is 1 1 over 2
and then light is replied to him saying
that this is an appearance paradox from
which one day useful consequences will
be drawn so this is the way that people
we believe that the fractional calculus
for the large that you know there have
been many mathematicians worked in this
area they try to define it and they were
very successful some of marsh as I
listed here reema Louisville prior
Lagrange uhler so many mathematicians
and there are three main directions of
this fractional calculus one direction
is done by Riemann Louisville and in my
research I also follow the rhema
Louisville direction how they define I'm
gonna show you and then the second one
is capital and the third one is Grunwald
letting go letting off recently so many
research going on in fractional calculus
as well as discrete fractional Cato's
mathematicians are also defining new
ways of generalizing this integer order
derivatives integer order integra's so
too much research is going on but these
are the three main directions
we start with gamma function because
gamma plays an important role when we
defined fractional order derivatives as
well as frictional order difference
equations or difference operator so
behave this first kind improper integral
as gamma function and we have this graph
and 10-15 minutes ago we also saw the
three-dimensional version of this graph
by the main speakers showed us what we
are interested in is the time positive
so it has the convex to property and we
are not worrying about the left left
hand side of the x axis because we are
going to model the growth curves or
tomorrow growths so we need to just look
at the past x axis for this graph it
satisfies the functional difference
equation and as we know it's the
generalization of pictorial function so
gamma n is n minus 1 factorial there are
many books in fractional differential
equations and I like to point out one on
fractional differential equations by
portal Omni this book was written 1999
and it has many applications first it
explains how to work with fractional
differential equations and then there
are many examples given in physics given
in economics even in other areas so i'm
going to show you two ways to define a
fractional difference operator let's
start with the noble operator number is
the backward operator difference
operators so now the f of t is f of t
minus f of t minus 1 so if you know you
know the value of the function right now
take the difference between the value of
the function
at the previous point to get the knob
off f it is kind of slope but not
exactly because this B are using the
discrete data here then we work with
mobile operators van der worp it
discrete calculus we don't use the
polynomials of real calculus that's what
I should say or continues calculus so
instead of polynomials like T to the t
su kare t cube a VST to the are rising
powers so they are defined with the
gamma function so teach the are rising
is gamma T plus R over gamma of T what
does this too in a when we take the
derivative of T Square it is true tea
isn't it did it comes down subtract one
from the derivative not operator does
the same thing for today for the teacher
are rising power so if I hate teach tyfa
writing either comes down subtract one
from the power that's what the nobler is
doing for this term or for this single
polynomial i should say monomial then i
like to compare teach the Alpha be a bit
T to the Eiffel bar T to the authorizing
so we also got this with Mathematica but
you know mathematica has gamma function
so you can see how they are close to
each other when alpha is close to one
now exponential function there is a
generation of exponential function in
mathematics this exponential function
generalized by me talk leffler French
mathematician in 1903 and later Ravi
agarwal mathematician recent
mathematician he generalized this for
two parameters which I found beta so if
you replace this iphone beta bit one
the office one day there is one done we
are getting ito x okay so what I'm going
to do is this I'm gonna replace oh let
me tell you about the discrete natok
left our function in 2 2011 I work with
poly low he is at universe of taken Ohio
and we had series of papers together in
the about the base basics of discrete
fractional calculus so we at one time we
were able to see what the generalization
of me talk left our function for
discrete case so here it is but I can
show you what this does so for the
discrete calculus 1 plus a 2 T is the
exponential function so this exponential
function generalized as 1 plus a 2 T
which corresponds to e 2 80 so it is a
discrete version of e2 80 or at combats
go the first one is a precalculus book
has it the first one it is known as a
convex curve and the second one is the
discrete version B road to describe
introduced the discrete version what we
did here each line see there we replace
with the discrete you know exponential
function and then continues frictional
will replace eat mine city with the mid
top left our function and we replace the
discrete with exponential function with
discrete fractional metric loeffler
function so then we asked ourselves if
we replace all this with the new
functions what do we get so we looked at
the parameter estimations and of course
we use Mathematica and we work with for
graduate students bombard curve is only
one we also work with
Babel Richards and lodges the curves for
data fitting and at that time we were
collaborating this one another medical
doctor and we use 17 views the data
which was collected from the mice who
did not receive any treatment and each
data includes 17-day data points because
data was collected in 17 days and we've
published our papers in this progress in
fractional differential equations and
applications differentiation and
applications so million rushed risk is
the one that who gave us the beta and we
work with statista now then we get the
new data from Dana Marshall we put all
the data in a XY coordinate system these
are discrete by the way these are the
collection of thoughts we just combine
them and make the line graph that's what
we call now for this Neve data we use
the doubt operate the operator is
another difference operate it is it can
constitute as approximation operator for
slope where the case limit H it for the
limit h is one or delta expand you call
it Delta X is 1 for nany Wharf it down
operator down the unity to the are
following functions these are the
polynomials again if you want to go with
the dot operator these are the teacher
are following functions represents
polynomials single term of the
polynomial again monomial so that when
you applied the dot operator till it
comes down subtract one from the
derivative and here is the
directional some operators and you know
I just want to move on because let me
just tell you that for the Riemann
Louisville frictional difference
operators here is how we do define for
example if you have 1 over 2 here's what
you need to do is rewrite 1 over 3 s 1
minus one-half which gives you 1 over 2
but then you take this and not as
downtown so this is going to be Delta F
minus one-half or one-half power of the
f means one-half some operate one half
older summer parade anyway for the new
data let me show you we work with the
slopes so if you do if the data is given
you can calculate slope so this is the
the one that what you do is you take the
difference between any two consecutive
points to get this line graph but then
for the frictional all the colorful and
other dots there corresponds fractional
cases so for example we just want to
know how the frictional gets closer or
gets away from the you know the the
slope which is the difference between
two data items if you are not familiar
with the bombards the virtual equation
here it is what you need to do is you
divide each side x 1 x of t you do this
substitution and you get this linear
differential equation and it's very easy
so this linear equation once you solve
it you put it back your sub substitution
and you obtain the boom-bust curve here
is what we did in our research we
replace the first order derivative let
me go back yeah the big
the first line is replace the first
order derivative by frictional order
difference operator so here it is that
the interesting thing in this modeling
is this new year's bit feeling what we
expect as a mathematician you know I
expect to see the news between zero and
one that's not the case the new is
between zero and one point five so we
are going little bit about one so this
could be considered first order second
order at together at the same time we
don't know how to solve this equation we
cannot use Mathematica to get the data
fitting because matematica does it use
an algorithm to approximate the
differential equation if your equation
is nonlinear then using the ML algorithm
to it to give you the fit for the given
data so since we cannot use research for
other methods there are other methods
but the one which fits for our cases
partial sum method and we calculate RSS
you know for our models it does really a
good job we wrote the discrete case
improvement is nine 3.85 prasad and for
the comparison with the discrete and
discrete frictional discrete frictional
gives us food percent improvement and we
also looked at the statistics of what we
are doing in terms of feeding we looked
at as a value and our scar SE and our
scar is higher is the result is better
and we got boot as high or fourth trip
discrete case and a discreet fractional
case so we start with the claim that
this model does better job and it does
that statistic shows that it does a very
good job in terms
fitting so now most of us turn to finish
up this talk okay now she talked about
this this method here and where is that
and she is simply called ml that that's
the matter there to solve such an
equation I don't know market levenberg
that's an algorithm to solve such a such
an equation is that right if there is no
solution for the equation so you find
some approximation in that algorithm
what they did they divide the data in
two pieces given data in two pieces a
form the equation to find the find
approximation and then we were working
on that and then and and hear what we
did okay why we are dividing data in two
pieces let's say that L is our data in
rather than dividing L in a half I start
looking all possible division starting
from index two and then we searched
through and then form the equation among
those among those and the retriever is
giving them the best solution in fact in
this data we find that half is not
giving the best solution so that's what
we did here we find those indexes
running from to that means starting from
the second item in the array all the way
to do the length minus 2 and we form the
slope and everything and then salt find
a solution for a B and then determine
their what is their the best solution
best date of hitting and then if you if
you look at that maybe I can show you
here and and we have that we have those
data here this is the this is the this
experiment that high school student did
for all the data that we had
come on a little bit faster okay hear
this so if you look at this example and
all the way down here see that the best
value is that the index is 000.00 45 the
first index which is to that means not
really the the division in half is the
best solution the first index index 2 is
the best solution okay so so this
approaches a little bit better than than
ml approach and if you look at them if
you look at them the other cases all the
discrete cases and here and you will see
that well the index 9 is the better now
if you look at the nine our data is like
we have 16 17 something like that so
nine is what a little bit over the half
so that's that that's better solution
than the Hat dividing my half ok so that
was for the discrete cases and we have
fractional also hear cases in that case
the only thing is that that different is
the calculation of slope okay if I go to
hear how do I go that well and this is
Moscow too so this is the this is the
discrete fractional cases here slope
compilation is is different than the
previous one the all the main idea is is
different and then of course here
because of that alpha ranging from 0 to
1.5 we had to have two loops there to
check all possible cases among them pick
the minimum one ok so again the main
idea here is that indexes is is not
dividing the the input into half but
looking all possible division and then
finding the best possible solution
Amanda that that was our improvement and
I don't know maybe this can be
generalized in mathematica and
introduced as an if you know algorithm
to do for data that you cannot have the
actual solution but find some kind of
approximation such an algorithm does not
exist nalga in Mathematica now I think
this is this is what I my part was
implementing those algorithms and then
in testing the result